Today we will look at immigration.
Who wins the game of immigration and who
loses? Why do they win? Why do they
lose? Okay, so let's look at the United
States, which is where most immigrants
go. And as you can see from this chart,
there are certain ethnic groups that do
better than other ethnic groups. So um
the Indian people
make the most money in America. And this
makes sense because um India has a very
competitive college system where only
the best and brightest get into their
technical institutes and then after
college they go United States to do
graduate work. Then they go on to
Silicon Valley to become uh engineers,
some become doctors. But Indians as a
demographic are very successful. Then um
you have the other Asian groups. So,
Japanese, Korean, Filipino, Chinese also
do very well. Uh, East Asians do very
well in school and East Asians are known
for being very hard workers.
The white people are the majority and
they are the average, okay? And they
make about 70,000 US a year. This is um
just average income. But then what's
troubling is that as you go lower, you
find that there are certain ethnic
groups that don't do well economically.
They include, of course, um, Mexicans,
Latinos, as well as
black Americans who traditionally have
been slaves in America. So the question
for us today is that why is it that
there are certain ethnic groups
specifically East Asian groups that uh
do well economically and then you have
other ethnic groups specifically
[snorts] Latinos and blacks who do not
do well economically.
Okay. So the traditional explanation is
that it's just that certain cultures
prize education more than other
cultures.
In fact, some extremists will go on to
say that genetically
East Asians are just smarter than
everyone else. Okay, so this is the PISA
rankings. This is from 2018. the pieces
is um the program for international
student assessment. So every three years
the OECD which is which is international
organization around the world they
organize tests for 14 year olds in three
subjects math science and reading and
based on these results the OCD which is
primarily concerned with economic
development forecast a nation's ability
to do well economically in the next 10
20 30 years. As you can see from this
map, [snorts] there are certain
countries that do outstanding on the
pizza. The nations in green do really
well. Uh the nations in yellow are
average and then there are these red
nations that are below average, meaning
that they will suffer economically. Now,
as you can see, the nations that do
really well are actually based primarily
in East Asia and they are Japan,
South Korea,
Vietnam, China. That's why a lot of
people believe that in the future, East
Asia will come to dominate the world
economically. In fact, there are many
who believe that already East Asia
dominates the world economically,
especially China. Then you have these
other nations in red that uh will suffer
economically. Uh you have Latin and
South America who traditionally have not
have not done very well on the pizza.
You also have Africa and the Middle East
that suffers
um on a pizza and then you have
Indonesia, Malaysia, these countries
that don't do well on the pizza. The
nations in are gray by the way are
nations that are are that have don't
have the development in order to
actually have students take tests. Okay?
They don't have the infrastructure, the
logistics to actually have students take
tests. And so what you can see about the
nations in red is first of all they're
primarily based in a region okay Latin
and South America but also you can
actually group them also by religion
okay Islam
okay Muslims don't do well on the pizza
and that's why there's great fear that
uh Islamic countries will fall behind
economically
also So another concern is immigration.
So what's been happening is that um
immigrants from Latin South America have
been moving to United States
and Islamic um um nations the people
have been moving to Europe. Okay. Now a
lot of this this immigration is driven
by war. So nations like Libya, Syria,
Afghanistan, Iraq have seen them have
seen the themselves destroyed because
America's war on terror forcing millions
of refugees to seek better opportunities
in Europe. Okay. And so this is causing
a lot of conflict because on one hand um
these immigrants
don't do well economically.
Um, on the other hand, they're moving to
these very wealthy nations and that's
causing a lot of conflict. So, what's
driving this conflict?
Okay, so again, from the pizza rankings,
it seems as though East Asians will come
to dominate the world. The problem is
that when you actually look at American
society and you look at who succeeds, it
turns out East Asians don't do as well
as you think they do. Well, if East
Asians are the best students in school
and they go on to the most prestigious
colleges and they are the smartest with
the highest IQ, you would think they
would come to dominate American society.
But that's not true actually. So um this
is a chart of new CEOs and what this
means is that from about 2000 Americans
corporations they tried their best to
bring in more diversity
into the corporate boardroom. Okay.
Traditionally CEOs American corporations
have been white middle-aged
uh and men. So they're trying to
diversify the leadership of American
corporations. And it turns out that
white women, okay, have done the best,
white women have been the most
successful in climbing the corporate
ladder in America.
Um, what's interesting now then is that
Latino and African-American men, okay,
they do okay. Not great, but they do
okay. And who is underperforming are
East Asian men. Okay, you can see this
from this map where the growth in East
Asian man it's pretty steady. Now there
are different reasons for this. Okay,
one reason is just that um there's
something called DEI DEI in America
diversity, equity, inclusion. And the
idea of DEI is to uh redress historical
wrongs. And one historical wrong is the
fact that women minorities
have been discriminated against in
American society and therefore they
should be given better opportunities
more opportunities to succeed. Okay. So
um you can argue that because of DEI
East Asian men have been discriminated
against because historically people
believe that East Asian men have not
been discriminated against even though
that's not that's not correct. Okay. So
you can argue it's really DEI but
another way of understanding this is
figure out who succeeds in corporate
America. And the answer is if you look
at the qualities of successful
uh CEOs well first of all they tend to
be aggressive
okay or assertive
[snorts]
okay another saying this is that they
have high risk tolerance
or they take chances.
Um also to navigate corporations you
need high EQ okay emotional
intelligence,
empathy
uh or collaboration skills.
Okay. Um
so these are the skills you need in
order to do well in American
corporations. And unfortunately
these certain skills
um the the uh stereotype is that East
Asian men don't actually have these
skills. As Asian men are tend to be much
more individualistic.
They're they tend to be um more cautious
and they tend not to speak a lot. Okay.
Um, so East Asian men are not known for
being articulate, which is something
that you need in order to do well in a
corporate boardroom where there's a lot
of debate, where there's a lot of
argumentation,
where where you have to present your
view, your opinion very coherently.
Okay. So, what's interesting is that the
skills that you need to do well in the
corporate boardroom,
um, East Asian men don't have. And you
can also argue that it's because East
Asian men don't have these skills. They
have other skills that allows them to do
well in school. For example, East Asian
men are more focused. They're more
unitarian. They're uh grave obsessed.
They are um more uh compliant, more
obedient. Okay? They like listening to
authority and that's why they do well in
school. But what this means ultimately
is a situation in which even though East
Asian men do well economically and they
do well academically,
their status, okay, status
in America is not as great as their
income would suggest. In fact, you could
make the argument that East Asian men
are among
um the groups that have the lowest
status in America, which makes no sense.
But again, unfortunately, the evidence
bears us out, especially
okay, the dating market.
Okay. So again, remember what is it that
men want to do? Well, they want to
obtain status so that they can find the
most attractive mate. Okay. So, um we're
going to now look at statistics from
dating websites. Okay. Online dating
websites. This is from Okay Cupid.
Okay. Okay. uh which is one of the more
popular um dating websites in the United
States. And so we have a lot of
statistics about how people behave
online. So look at this guys, okay? If
you are an Asian female
and a Asian man gets in touch with you,
about 22%
of these Asian female will respond to an
inquiry, a first message if the person
is an Asian man. But what's interesting
is that if it's more white guy,
then there's more interest. 29%. That's
a pretty significant difference. Okay.
So, this is just a first reply. Now,
what's interesting is that um if you're
an Asian
uh male, okay, [snorts]
what's interesting is that people are
less likely to respond to you. Okay. So,
this is another map that shows us stat
statistics from the uh dating website.
Okay. So, this is
um
white woman. Okay. Let's look at white
woman and there and how interested they
are in other ethnicities. If you are
white, okay, Caucasian, they're very
interested. In fact, they're the most
interested.
If you're black, they're not as
interested. Okay? If you're Hispanic,
they're not interested. But look at
this. If you're Asian,
they are least interested.
Okay? That's interesting. Um, but look
at this. If you are an Asian woman,
okay,
you're pretty interested in white guys.
You're most interested in Asian guys,
okay? and you're similarly interested in
black and Hispanic guys. So, it seems
that in the dating market, one group
that is most discriminated against are
ease Asian men. Okay. Another group um
that's also discriminated against
heavily are black women. Okay.
[snorts]
All right.
Okay. So if you if you look at marriage
patterns, there's also discriminate
discrimination against East Asian men.
Okay. So
20%
of East Asian women will marry white
guys.
Okay? So, if you are an East Asian
woman, you are attracted to white guys
and you're attracted to East Asian guys
primarily.
But if you are an East Asian men, okay?
All right. Here,
you're not that attractive to white
women. Okay? So
20% of East Asian women will marry a
white person, but only 9% or 10% of
Asian men will marry a white woman. So
this leads to a disparity in the
marriage market. And what this means is
that uh for East Asian men under 25
years old, 75% are single, meaning they
cannot find a date or a partner. Okay.
Okay. So, this leads to a very very
stark conclusion for East Asian men. The
reality is that if you're an East Asian
man in America,
people don't find you that attractive.
Okay? So, they did a lot of studies
about the East uh about the dating
market in America. And the radical
conclusion that they have is that is
this. Okay.
A white
woman, okay,
is more attracted to a white man than an
Asian man.
And how do we know this statistically? A
if a white man makes $62,000 a year, for
the Asian man to be as attractive to
her,
the man, the Asian man needs to make
$300,000 a year. That's a huge, huge
difference.
In other words, a white woman will be
attracted to the average white guy
and she will only be interested in the
highest earning Asian
guys.
Okay? But not not only are they making a
lot, but these Asian guys are actually
at the top of their fields because
$200,000 in America is actually a lot of
money. Okay? So, you have to be a
surgeon. You have to be a top lawyer.
You have to be an entrepreneur in order
to be attractive to just the average
white woman, not even the the most
attractive white woman. So, this is
actually a pretty stark situation for
Asian men. And so, you have a really
strange situation where
Asian men, East Asian men, did
everything right. They they did exactly
what they were supposed to do. They went
to school, worked hard in school, got
the best grades, then worked hard at
their jobs and got and did very well in
their jobs. But now two things have
happened because they follow the rules
because they living right. They didn't
commit any crime. They're not on
welfare. They pay taxes. They're they
can contribute to community. But because
of this, two things have happened. One
is that they're not able to climb into
status positions in America. They're not
CEOs. The other thing is that they have
problems finding a very good mate. Okay.
It's easy for them to find someone off
their status or below, but it's very
hard for East Asian man to actually
marry up and improve their status and
social economic standing in America.
All right.
So, this leads us to a very very stark
uh disparity, right? So, let's look at
this guys. You have East Asian men
[snorts] and here's how they play the
game of immigration.
Uh they do well in school.
Okay. They have good jobs, employment.
Yes,
they have uh they're not on welfare.
Okay,
they don't go to jail.
Okay, and then you look at um other
minorities. Okay, specifically
Hispanic, black, and um Muslim. Okay.
Well, they don't do as well in school.
Okay. They don't do they don't make as
much as ease Asian man. Uh they're more
likely to be on welfare and they're more
likely to go in jail. Okay.
All right.
So, you would think that East Asian men
will ultimately triumph in the end. But
what is really disconcerting is that
according to game theory,
East Asian men are playing the game
wrong. Whereas these other groups,
these um Hispanics, these blacks, these
Muslim groups,
they are much more likely to win the
game. Okay. So, how can we explain this?
And the explanation is actually pretty
straightforward, but it's actually very
disconcerting or very disturbing. The
the answer is
if someone invites you to play his game,
don't agree to play by the rules because
the game is out so that you will lose.
Otherwise, why would he invite you?
Think of a casino, right? A casino is
like please come in and play our game.
Do you think a casino is fair? If the
casino was were fair, the casino will go
bankrupt, right? The casino is set up so
that you have to lose otherwise they go
out of business. The same thing with
immigration. If a nation like United
States is inviting you into their nation
and you play by their rules,
you will always lose. Okay? And this is
what's happening to East Asian men where
they go to the United States, they play
by the rules
and they'll never climb into sus
positions and their woman will be
married off to white men. The most
attractive of all Asian women will be
married off to white guys, whereas East
Asian guys will make their money and
then stay at home and play video games
all the time. [snorts]
Okay, the game is rigged. So the only
logical
strategy according to game theory to
this situation is to break the game,
cheat. Okay? And that's what the other
minorities are doing. And how do you do
that? Well, you don't play the game. You
don't go to you don't go to school and
obey the teacher.
Okay. What how to win is by sticking
together and having lots of babies. And
over time that will enable you to win
the game because of demographics. Okay?
Does that make sense? You're much better
off not going to school, being poor, but
staying together, being cohesive, and
having lots of babies rather than going
to school, getting a good job, doing
everything you've been told to do.
Because ultimately, your energy
will be stolen from you because of the
rules of the game. Okay? Does that make
sense, guys? All right. All right.
So okay. So again immigration is very
important because all in the world
poor people are going to rich countries
to seek better opportunities right so
it's really um North America primarily
United States Canada the United States
then you have um Australia
um New Zealand
and Europe. Okay.
And
countries that are going to these place
places are China, East Asia basically,
um and you have the um Latinos,
the Africans,
uh Middle East. Okay.
All right. And again, you have situation
where East Asians are much more likely
to go and conform, but then you have
other groups that go and refuse to
conform. And as I mentioned, from a game
theory perspective, it is better in the
long term for you as a person not to
conform, not to play the rules of the
game than to actually play by the rules
of the game. I know it sounds weird,
okay? But according to game theory,
that's the best outcome for you. All
right. So, um, an example is in Europe.
Okay. In Europe, they have a huge Muslim
problem. These Muslims are less likely
to integrate. Uh, they don't do very
well in school, but they will claim
welfare. they will have lots and lots of
babies which is a drain on the uh
economy of these nations and what this
means is that in the year uh 2050 okay
in the year 2050 this is what's going to
happen in Sweden
of the population will be Muslim in the
UK 17% in France 17% in Germany 11%
the in Italy it'll be 12%. Okay, so it
seems as though there's a population
replacement going on.
But not only that, but because Muslims
are much more likely to have more
children than Europeans,
the populations that are Muslim will be
younger,
more energetic,
whereas the Europeans will be much more
old. They'll likely be retired. So if
this trend continues
then Europe will eventually be taken
over by the Muslim minority.
Okay?
And so the Muslims they don't do well in
school and they don't make that much
money but look at their advantages.
Okay. First of all they are cohesive.
Okay. Because of their religion.
Okay. They are energetic
because you're young.
Okay? And they're united because quite
honestly uh the Europeans don't really
like them. They're they are an outcast.
They're considered an enemy by the
Europeans.
>> [snorts]
>> So if trends continue then it is most
likely that Muslims will will control
Europe in
25 years time. Okay? Does it make sense?
But not only that, but you look at
America. Okay? Let's look at America.
You have a similar situation
going on.
Sorry. Okay. Look at 2050. What's
happening? Okay.
All right. So, the white population is
declining. Okay. Right now, it's a
majority, but by 2050 it will no longer
be the majority. Um, Asians are
increasing by a bit, but not that much.
Okay. But the real growth is in
Hispanics. In Hispanics.
Okay. And not only are they going in
absolute numbers, but again they're are
much more young, much more energetic uh
group who are more likely to have
children. Okay? And they are united
because they are Catholics.
So they have a common religion, they
have a common language,
they have a they have very similar
common cultural um traits. So that's it.
According to game theory, if you're an
immigrant, your best strategy is not to
do well in school, make a lot of money.
That will get you nowhere. You're just
playing by the rules of the game. Your
best strategy is to stick together with
your ethnic group,
have lots of babies, maintain your
religion, and over time, your children,
your grandchildren will come to dominate
the nation. Okay? Does that make sense,
guys? Any questions before I move on?
Okay. The problem with this is that
there is no way that the majority, the
white people will just sit back and let
this happen. Okay? You're going to have
a lot of violence, a lot of conflict
because from the white perspective, this
is population
replacement.
Okay? If we just let demographic trends
continue, if these outsiders just have a
lot of kids and we don't have the kids,
then eventually our culture will be
destroyed.
And they're right. Okay, historically
they're right. And how do we know?
Because let's talk about some history.
All right, so last semester we talked
about the protoindo-uropeans,
right? Okay. So this is Europe. [snorts]
This is Asia.
Uh Anatolia.
Okay. So remember that after the ice
age,
hunter gatherers spread around. Okay.
Okay. You have hund gatherers around.
But then because as the uh earth was
warming this allowed for agriculture and
so a new group came into being that
focused on agriculture. Okay, these are
the farmers.
These are farmers and they arrived
primarily in Anatolia and the Leavant
and Mesopotamia because that was the
warmest part of the globe that was most
amendable to agriculture. But then if
you remember there's always climate
change and because of climate change
they're not forced to migrate okay and a
lot migrated to Europe and when they
went to Europe they forced out the
hunter gatherer okay it was not violent
because hunter gatherers have very few
people and they allow and they can move
about okay but eventually what happened
is that the farmers were able to
displace place the hunter gatherers.
Okay, now they're established in Europe.
You also had uh farmers who went into
the steps,
but remember from last semester we
discussed the steps and how because it's
grassland, you can't actually farm there
or it's very hard to farm there. So they
develop a new economy called uh nomadic
pasturalism
which is to say that they raised sheep,
goat and cows and they migrated from one
area of the grassland to the next. Okay.
And as a result they became very strong
very aggressive people and again because
of overpopulation because of climate
change these people are now forced to
migrate to Europe. Okay they migrate to
Europe and what happened now? Well, now
there's a war that lasts 100 years, 20
years in which the pneumatic
pastoralists, the Annayia or the Puerto
Indo-Uropeans, they displaced or they
eliminated the the farmers. Okay? And so
what happened, we know this from genetic
studies, is that the men, the uh
European farmers were killed and the
woman were taken as basically bride uh
brides, okay? slaves basically. Okay, so
this is a population replacement
and this historically
is what happens. Okay, one group comes
in and replaces the other. And
throughout most of human history, this
is a constant cycle because the steps
were extremely violent and chaotic. And
this forces groups to constantly migrate
to other places in search of safety.
And in each time there is population
replacement. Okay.
Primarily in the elite.
Okay.
So we so there are very few instances of
um situ where groups come together and
they
are peaceful. No because you you only
have one elite and and one elite must
replace the other elite. Okay? Does
doesn't make sense guys? All right. So
if this is historically the situation,
how did we get into a situation where
immigration has become the norm in
today's world?
Okay, before historically we believe
that you have to stay together as part
of your group otherwise you'll be
eliminated. And now we believe that hey
if you don't like where you are it's
okay just get up and move somewhere else
and maybe it'll be better better
economic opportunities for you. This is
a shift in mentality a shift in mindset.
Okay. This came about because of the
British Empire.
All right. Okay. So this is Europe.
[snorts]
This is South America.
Uh, USA,
Canada,
um, Australia,
New Zealand. Okay. All right.
So
you have Spain
and Spain because of the Ottoman Empire,
Spain could not access
the uh East Indies trade. Okay. So it
had to figure out new ways to access uh
East Asia, China.
Uh China
India
because that was where a lot of spices
were. Okay. And there's huge demand for
spices. So they started to chart new new
areas. Okay. Spain and Portugal
primarily. And what they discovered was
there's all this new territory in South
America. Now South America is
interesting because in South America you
had a huge population and there was a
lot of mineral wealth, silver and gold.
And so what they could do was they go
could go over there and enslave the
population. Okay. So, slavery
and then you convert them to to Catholic
religion.
All right. So, basically the easiest
areas to colonize Spain and Portugal
took right right away. But then
afterwards
um
Britain,
England start to play this game as well.
Okay.
And they also sent colonists.
But the problem was that there was no
large population to enslave also there
were a lot especially United States
there were a lot of aggressive uh
Indians. Okay. Natives. And so the
solution was the United States after one
independence from Britain, it welcomed
immigrants from Europe specifically um
Ireland, uh Germany, Poland, these
places. The reason why is they needed to
displace the natives.
Okay?
And then immigrants were uh were then uh
encouraged to go to Canada and Australia
to build their economies as well.
So in other words, immigration today it
is a historical accident.
The Americans were responding to the
specific needs of that time. Okay? They
were a small population against a
hostile people, the natives in a very
large area. And so they needed people to
come and farm and industrialize the
area. And that's why America welcome
immigrants. And this is uh new in human
history
where you could go to a new place and
become a citizen. Okay? [music]
Usually if you went to a new place, you
went because you were a slave. You were
conquered in war and you went as cheap
labor. Okay? So in so America they
welcome you as um citizens if you're
willing to contribute and they allow you
to get rich if you worked hard. Okay.
Now fast forward and America becomes an
empire because it's allowing all this
energy to concentrate in America. You
have World War II. Okay? You have World
War II
and America triumphs in World War II.
And now America can set the entire rules
of the game for most of the world for
Western Europe. And at this time America
said to Europe, you guys fought wars.
You guys had fascism because you are a
closed society. Okay? Close society
means you don't want immigrants. You're
all very nationalistic and therefore
you are violent. America won the war
because America is an open society which
welcomes immigrants which is a
multicultural society that encourages
people to get rich and be happy. And so
Europe, if you want to be like us, if we
want to prevent World War II, then you
have to become an open society as well
and welcome immigrants just like we do.
[snorts]
Okay?
And that's why we have the situation
that where we have where now uh Muslims
are going to Europe and others are going
to America.
Okay. And what um we need to recognize
is that immigration it's a new game
developed because of certain historical
circumstances but it's not sustainable
in the long term. And so the idea that
you can just work hard in school, then
go to America and become wealthy, that
can't be true anymore. In the future,
according to game theory, what's going
to happen are these violent conflicts
between demographic groups because each
group is trying to set the rules of the
game. Because whoever sets the rules of
the game will always win the game.
Meaning they have access to the best uh
jobs. They have the high status and they
have access to the best looking woman
which is ultimately what every um man is
looking for. Okay. Status, attractive
woman, power, money.
All right. Does that make sense, guys?
All right. Any questions?
Okay. Ask one question, then we'll we'll
we'll we'll we'll we'll finish class.
Okay.
Can we really do something about the
current immigration or we don't have any
ability to change it?
>> Okay. Um, that's a great question and
I'm sure everyone's everyone's feeling
with this question which is like what
can we do about this situation?
Well, I mean
the problem is, and I hate to say this,
but immigration is not natural.
Okay? And what I mean by that is that if
you're born into a community, what is
natural is for you to want to help this
community grow and develop. You want to
contribute to this community. What is
not natural is for you to say, you know
what, this community sucks. I'm going to
go find a new community because if
everyone did that then no communities
could ever exist. Okay. So 99% of people
what their natural inclination to do is
to want to work hard and make the
community a better place. And that's
what everyone should be doing. You
always going to have minority people
maybe 1% 2% who are sort of strange and
that they have different ideas and
they're not going they're not going to
be able to conform to the community.
Okay. And historically these people have
been killed by the communities and so
it's natural for them to get up and
leave. Okay. So uh but that's only a
small group of people. So what's what is
natural is for people to want to just
stay where they are because they love
their neighbors because they love their
family and they want to help the
community get stronger and stronger.
And unfortunately because because of
globalization
uh because of mass media because of the
internet for another reason young people
believe that what's important is their
own individual happiness
uh their own economic opportunity. So
I'm going to go wherever there's more
economic opportunity. So for example,
Chinese students, the very best are
like, you know what, I'm probably going
to make more money United States, so I'm
going to work hard, then immigrate to
United States, and then um start my own
company, get rich and all that. And you
know, some people have success of doing
that. But if you think about it, this is
not good for China, right?
as a nation, why would you encourage
your best and brightest to take their
skills, move somewhere else, and contri
contribute to that economy rather than
to your own economy? And so, we're in a
very strange situation. And we are in
this situation because for the longest
time, America was a global hedgeimon and
could write the rules of the game. And I
keep on telling you guys this, whatever
writes the rules of the game will always
win. Okay? So globalization was system
so that America could extract from the
world resources.
Um and these resources include talent.
Okay. So we have a situation where the
best and brightest go to America because
that's where they're most likely to
thrive.
But now um the world is changing.
America is now becoming is no longer the
global hedgeimon.
Russia, China, these countries are
rising as well. And so nations now are
much more interested in being able to
maintain their best and brightest, their
talent, their human capital. And this is
the way it should be. If you're born in
China, then your priority ought to be
like how to make China a better place.
It shouldn't be like I'm work really
hard in school so that I can get a visa
to go study United States. That makes no
sense.
Okay? So, um, and look, the reality is
that,
um, if you states, you can make a lot of
money, but you're still going to be low
status. Okay? Okay. And that's the
situation I found myself in in North
America where, you know, I worked really
hard in school. I went to Yale and I
could have made a lot of money as a
lawyer or as a doctor, but I recognized
that, you know what, if I just stay
where I am,
I'm not going to um ever achieve my
potential. I'm not going to achieve
status in America. I may be wealthy, but
I'm never going to have achieved high
status. You know, that's why I chose to
come to China because I thought there
were more opportunities to obtain higher
status in China than in United States
where I'm not white. I'm East Asian and
there's going to be a lot of stereotypes
and prejudice against me because I'm
East Asian.
Okay. And quite honestly, I was right in
my assessment.
All right. So I So yeah, you're you're
saying what can East Asians America do
about this? Right.
And unfortunately, according to game
theory, they're stuck where they are.
Okay,
that's why, you know, I chose to leave.
But if you're East Asian in America, I'm
not saying for everyone, okay? I'm sure
there are like thousands of very happy
East Asians who married very well and
they have very good lives. Okay? But for
the majority,
um, you can have decent lives, but
you're always going to be low status.
And quite honestly, a lot of East Asians
are happy with that situation. A lot of
East Asians are just happy, you know,
getting by, uh, making good money, and
they really don't worry about status.
Okay? But the problem is that their
children and grandchildren are kind of
screwed over because it's going be very
hard for them to uh marry. Okay? And
again, there's there's a lot of East
Asian men who are single and they have
very and they have problems on the
dating market. Okay.
All right.
Any more questions, guys?
Is that clear?
>> Great. Okay. So, we will continue this
uh next week.